ça c'est quoi c'est donner ce qu'il
faudrait faire
uderzo c'est simplement un petit cours
je crois pour tous nos amis qui
connaissent amalric
comment est-ce qu'on dessine astérix
voilà bon bah écoute et vous allez voir
c'est très simple il ya que des euros et
des avalanches
alors commence par par un ovale ça c'est
quoi
puis celle donnée à tient il à un héros
lui sans les moustaches rien dit je dis
non c'est sous ses pas son héros c'est
sûr j'ai appris le 16 heures et puis
alors encore noël
oui ce sont des routes des ovales je
veux être souvent la fureur c'est à dire
vous allez un peu vite évidemment ça
c'est cherundolo fut très longtemps
qu'ailleurs
s'ils font alors les aides sont un peu
plus pointu
voilà donc le noir tire un peu sur on
veut quand on a le temps voilà ces rixes
voilà bah c'est oui au fond c'est assez
facile une tradition dans les crabes
chaque dessinateur qui vient là
dessine la rencontre dans son personnage
avec dorothée oui une tradition et si
c'est vrai c'est toujours dorothée dans
les dessins c'est aussi bon alors
évidemment j'avais avancé par rapport
aux 1 et trop de temps elle en voulait
terminer le petit personnage va
conservation jallet sur le physique
c'est le dessert ici le dernier-né le
dernier jeu les mis un petit peu parce
que finalement on a tendance à l'oublier
et puis les pieds elle nous fait je
dessine possible et aussi vite les
camions et c'est un homme de télévision
pour le voit tout de suite tout ça ce
sont des meubles alors là il des
ressauts je ne vois pas de dorothée là
on pouvait la alors pour dorothée et
justement on n'a mis qu'un but va alors
tu vas être aidé
il va tenter sa casquette parce que je
n'ai pas tiens je vais tenir avec les
tarifs à la rentrée c'est là
mais j'en avais
bon ça vous reconnaissez quand vos lois
qu'est-ce qui est déçu bien c'est une
coproduction alors là alors c'est finir
là alors attention
est ce que j'ai a frappé aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]